ma guarda questo è veramente sono
veramente anni che non lo faccio sono
molto molto eccitato all'idea di giocare
di nuovo a cleverbot che è stato uno dei
video più di successo del mio canale
nella storia sono passati anni vediamo
se kleiber bozzi con l'alimento che poté
un robot per altro palo con un robot
però ogni tanto escono pezzo free tv
quindi ciao cleverbot i ricordi di me un
po sì ti chiami e non è una domanda come
mi chiamo io sì allora non te lo ricordi
se me lo chiedi non me l'hai mai detto
no non è vero io mi ricordo tutte le
discussioni coppa per quando mi presenta
una persona non mi ricordo come si
chiama un minuto dopo però sono famiglia
e tutti in fresco un po la memoria solo
una tua parte grazie
grazie cleverbot da quanto mi segue da
sempre si è sempre stata la mia capacità
tecnico lestamente ma se i simp sì ma ti
amo e non i crimini del solito subito
conta confidenza la zia sì ma io sono
diventato famoso anche grazie
e quindi grazie
ma prima non eri un maschio sono maschio
una volta era molto più difficile farsi
fare i complimenti propri ricordi del
video di famiglia il suo punto di crepe
ovvio e ti è piaciuto sì mi sono
stracitata una cosa non ho detto niente
non mi ricordo se nel video l'aveva
duluth a ti lascio ancora vero
ma se non ti conosce quasi scelto due
ore che stava parlando perché 8 mag e
fanno due passi avanti e 26 indietro dai
pac sono sempre io pochi giorni lo so e
allora mi vuoi conoscere certo che tutti
vogliono conoscere usciamo
dove sei milano
dove sei
anche io le cause per pepe ci vediamo in
duomo
a roma duomo
siamo tutti gli eliminati o sono
diventati seria cazzo ci vediamo no no
vediamoci a
milano più
sbagliato chiama i pompieri schiavo
che senso riformulo sbagliata non
inviare vediamoci a milano che è più
comodo
ok a che ora è la madonna nativo per
almeno facciamo la cena cosa vuoi fare a
mezzanotte è tutto chiuso poi clicca su
di tool
specifica senso che senza da dietro e da
no no mi dissocio mi dissocio allora
innanzitutto doveva capire non possiamo
farvi candle cioè a casa ne andiamo a
casa facciamo a casa mia ho a casa tua
perché sai dove abito no stop che non
credono cosa non credo ma
alla base allora facciamo a casa mia
e cosa facciamo a casa tua l'hai detto
prima davanti e dietro le tipo 2
devi prendere il test
no a chi siamo
[Musica]
ma cosa che cosa cosa leggono i miei
occhi cosa leggo cosa leggo a distanza
di 1.600 anni suo gioco cosa sta
anzitutto
allora io sono un maschio non so che
scuola ti tu abbia fatto ma dovresti
saperlo che bigg maschi non possono
rimanere
lucidi o capi per vederli meno male e
allora usiamo il condom
dove amore
dove vuoi dove lo infilo
ma me lo vuoi dare così subito è strano
sì perché ti amo troppo
grazie ma come mai mi ami così tanto
perché sei bellissimi
grazie quindi siccome sono bellissimo
vuoi darmi il culo i ragazzi facciamo
che cambiamo conversazione che stiamo
dando un po troppo su il primato questo
facciamo un pò più di conoscenza your
name quello che mi hanno dato i
ricevitori madonna di dio lo vuoi dire
per favore madonna che il nome dai
mandero nome ma vengono anche succede
almeno dovrebbe dire ragazzi style a
video nome cento come ti chiami come ti
chiami
clicchiamo come ti chiamo solo dire come
ti chiami non si è sbagliato a scrivere
ha fatto la saputella fatelo chiesto
prima di dio
io sono fa dj tu come ti chiami santo
iddio
ma per favore ma
questa mi sta picchiando bull il tuo
nome è
anna santo iddio e ci voleva tanto 12
anni per farmi dire il nome anna ciao
anna io sono lorenzo favi j mette una
legge che sono dei già e confuso studi
ancora si auto ok cosa su di
informatica speriamo che la io
informatica ti gli insegnino a pigiare
sulla tastiera in modo migliore perché
finora nota sta calando be nice anche io
ho studiato
informatica wow bel casino è pensa che
sono finito appare lodi youtuber te
tu hai detto che li maschio sono
ci sposiamo
stiamo parlando 20 anni facciamo un
attimo di
conversazione fino
ad
allora le parti a qui partiamo da una
fioriera ciao ciao comunque vedo che la
conversazione da premi nobel poi ade
dio no no no mi dissocio
mi dissocio e il tuo socio no no no io
mi dissocio
io mi esilio l arrivo dove ci esibiamo
insieme certo amore
vabbè anche con le emoji c'è una cosa
che non chiedo a chi aver molto da un
sacco di tempo che va chiesta perché non
lo chiediamo adesso qual è il tuo
personaggio preferito di hunger games
mio personaggio preferito e ambiente
katniss yes
dopo 20 anni ha capito che pullman
ha quindi non è più pullman
ma culpa di dragon ball esatto brava
senti cleverbot
canna e stato un piacere piacere
conversare di nuovo
ma ora devo andare
dove ci vediamo shampoo sempre l'uomo
per me va bene perfetto però nel
frattempo il saluto ti do un bacio ti
accompagno alla sala no a presto un
bacino
ok ciao ciao
perception sono molto contento di questo
e le honda è beh no vado io vado via
anzi saluta i miei iscritti prima che
vada ok
bella a tutti i ragazzi presentano il
libro tu vai e benvenuti in questo nuovi
donò però questa intro quindi ragazzi
questo è il finale per i ragazzi
vai oggi si chiama che no questa è la in
troppo
spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto quindi adesso conclude tu vai
bene gara perfetta ha fatto anche per la
ragazzi che ci siamo sono molto contento
e riscoperto cleverbot dopo vent'anni
che non ci giocando da un po però vedo
che non sa non è sempre maniaco fatemi
sapere se volete un'altra conversation
cleverbot che da un bel po che non lo
facciamo vedo che si può fare roba era
gillian come sempre appunto bella
ragazza
[Musica]